each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so today we're very pleased to have
Allison leuco speaking to us on
decentralizing attribute-based
encryption
allison is a PhD student at University
of Texas at Austin and winner of the MSR
graduate fellowship okay so I'm gonna be
talking about decentralizing attribute
based encryption also known as multi
authority attribute based encryption or
apparently known to both Denbo name is
adjective based encryption so yes is a
little mouthful so I'm gonna try to
explain sort of slowly what all these
what all these different modifiers mean
please ask a lot of questions I like
questions so just jump in if something
doesn't make sense this is joint work of
my adviser Brent waters at UT so in the
regular setting of public key
cryptography of course we have two users
we have a user Alice who like to send a
message to Bob but only has access to a
public channel so we have a solution to
this problem by having Bob generate a
public key and the secret key pair
Alice retrieves his public Keith uses
this to encrypt her message sends this
along to Bob who can use the secret key
to read it so in this setting we have a
very well-defined functionality very
nice notions of security but it's a bit
limiting in that we just have this sort
of two party model of one user
communicating with another user so more
generally what we'd like to do in the
public key setting like to get beyond
this notion of encryption as needing a
single known recipient of data so we'd
like to be able to have unknown
recipients many recipients people who
may even join the system in the future
who should have access to that data and
we'd also like to think more generally
beyond all-or-nothing data sharing so we
may have different recipients who should
be allowed to see different portions of
the data instead of just having a set of
users who can see the data and the set
of users who cannot so this motivates
the general notion of functional
encryption which is just a more general
framework for flexible data sharing so
we like to imagine that a user at the
time they encrypt their data can more
gener
we asked who should have access to my
data and what should they see I was a
particular example of this we have
attribute based encryption which was
introduced by Sahai and Watters and in
such a system ciphertext will be
associated with access formulas so a
user will describe the set of people who
can read their data in terms of a
formula over attributes so maybe I'll
encrypt my data so the only people who
are students at the University of Texas
should be able to read the ciphertext
and keys in such a system will be
associated with a Tribune's so I'll have
keys for the different attributes
associated with my identity perhaps I
have a key for student a key for Texas
key for for other things and decryption
will allow my key to decrypt the
ciphertext if the set of my attributes
satisfies the formula the ciphertext was
encrypted under hey any questions about
this basic setup yes yeah so this is
ciphertext policy so you could also have
key policy where you sort of reverse
these roles
so in that case keys would be associated
with formulas in cipher text would be
associated with attributes and you would
decrypt again if the attribute satisfy
the formula so you can sort of reverse
this for the multi authority systems
we're gonna talk about today we're going
to stay in key policy land sorry sorry
sorry text policy yeah so so this is
this is a framework understand but yeah
and more generally you could reverse
this hey other questions okay so but in
these in these attribute based in
encryption systems traditionally we have
one Authority who's giving out all the
keys so for instance as a concrete
example a company you may want to
encrypt a job posting with a formula
like this so you need both a master's
degree and more than two years of
experiencing and then the main security
challenge in the setting is we want to
prevent collusion attacks so for
instance we may have a user who has a
master's but has no experience and a
user who has experience but doesn't have
the degree we don't want them to be able
to get together and combine their infamy
to read the ciphertext so essentially we
want to prevent sort of the transference
of attributes from one user to another
to be able to use together and so so to
do this we vary these systems heavily
rely on the fact that there's one
central authority who's giving out all
the keys and this authority and this
authority can coordinate things to avoid
these collusion attacks however in in
the more general world we have
situations where we have multiple
authorities and multiple parties who
need to have access to something so a
very real-life example is if you have
sort of multiple companies or multiple
parties who need to access a shared
space but need to keep it locked then
you can use something called a multiple
lock what this is is each party has
their own individual lock in their own
individual key and opening any one lock
will open the gate but so if one party
loses their key or hazard key stolen you
just need to replace their one lock and
so it doesn't affect any of the other
parties so this is sort of decentralized
so this is decentralized process so you
don't have to get together and
coordinate every time you need to
recover from a lobster stolen key so
this is a real-life example of what we
would like to be able to do in the data
sharing world so a more data-driven
example suppose you have different
companies sort of coordinating different
services so you might have a service
that encrypts its content so that
someone who's either a subscriber to the
service can read it or perhaps someone
who's certified by other sponsors so
companies might get together and make
deals to provide services to each
other's customers or things like that
and so you may want these keys to be
distributed by sort of different
entities and different companies who
even more generally may not trust each
other and may not even know about each
other so for the most flexible and most
functional system we like to allow
authorities to sort of arise that will
not have to coordinate with each other
and not even have to know all the other
authorities in the system and they
shouldn't have to rely on each other for
the security of their own systems these
authorities can generate a key for for
you sir yeah the attributes that they
control so each authority will so
imagine an attribute as being sort of
concatenated with the identity of the
authority who controls it
so each Authority controls disjoint
attributes and so I can arise as an
authority in the system declare I'm
giving out attributes that satisfy this
and so users can just come to me and
start getting keys and I don't and other
authorities may not know I exist
multiple authorities get keys for
different subsets of attributes right
and then you can use them together so
like you may go to the DMV and get a key
for driver's license or go to your
company and get a key for employee and
and the DMV and your company don't have
to coordinate yes yeah yeah so I'll talk
about that yeah so the main challenge in
these systems is we still want to avoid
collusion so we still require that to be
secure I shouldn't be able to go to the
DMV and get a driver's license and use
it in conjunction with a key that you
get
okay so we'll talk about how we do that
yeah
some handle some cards I can serve as an
authority on my own and then generate
queues on my own and so but the key is
you generate will only be for the
attributes that you sort of publicly
declared belong to you so you can't
generate keys for someone else's
attributes so if someone encrypts this
that so say you say I control the
attribute a and someone encrypts a
ciphertext saying they need two hats
that's by attribute a yeah you can
decrypt it but if I encrypt a ciphertext
saying someone needs have attribute be
controlled by belissa
then you can't generate a key for that
so you won't be able to decrypt that you
know these guys can come in anytime yeah
so sort of the only centralization in
our system which I'll get to is there
some global setup parameters which is
out there in public yeah yeah so they
have to be generated a trusted way at
the beginning and I'll mention this
right so so there there is us have
global parameters that everyone will
need to mutually trust but that would
just be like published data somewhere
you could go pick up it won't be like a
person you have to coordinate with okay
but there is a global trust point this
is true we can't get we'd we don't know
how to get rid of that no they don't
have to get anything they just have to
look up these public parameters yes
yes so you have to trust the person who
created the parameters yeah and we'll
see we'll see why you can see very
specifically how it could be attacked
yes no parameters are just published
right I'm sorry I can take you to
yesterday's New York Times and use that
on my London well so so we'll see we get
to the setup algorithm but they have to
be generated and trusted away but once
they're generated they're out there and
then it's fine okay so as long as
they're generated by someone who's not
malicious and then published then it's
fine and that person doesn't need to
stay in the system they just published
them in leaf right so so you can think
about maybe every authority has an ID or
something and their attributes
concatenate their ID on the front so so
in our system users also will have
global IDs so so everyone the system
should have a global identifier no there
won't be secret information
corresponding to the global ID
okay all right so solo before I describe
sort of our system let me start by
saying how you can get you can get
someone close to this by just using
current single Authority a B and also a
secure signature scheme so to some
extent this this is done already so um
if we're willing to have a central
authority so this will be a globally
trusted entity who's always active in
the system so for willing to have such a
thing then we can have other authorities
who don't need to coordinate with each
other so if one central authority
everyone needs to know about and trust
and then we have other authorities who
can sort of do their own thing and a
user in this system will have a global
ID and we do need some sort of sort of
way of enforcing that users have
distinct gullible IDs okay so we're only
going to protect collusion up to
assuming that users have distinct go
ladies so a user can go get attributes
in the following way so authorities will
arrive
by publishing a verification key for the
signature scheme so an authority will
declare the attributes they control and
publish a verification key and so to get
a key for an attribute a user will go
interact with us with an authority using
their global ID the Authority will
decide that the user deserves to have
this attribute and they will sign a
certificate to that effect okay and they
will give the signature to the user so
user can go at different times the
different authorities using their same
global ID collect these signatures for
all of its attributes and then all at
once it will take all these signatures
to the central authority central
authority will verify all the signatures
and uncheck the users global ID and
we'll create the keys and the attribute
based single Authority system
corresponding to those attributes and
give these keys to the user okay and
then the user can use these to decrypt
ciphertext so this at least gives us a
partial a decentralized system because
these other authorities don't need to
know about each other or interact with
each other but we still are relying on a
central authority who has to be
constantly giving out keys so the
drawbacks of this approach are twofold
so first of all we have this globally
trusted entity who's constantly active
so they're constantly in the system and
potentially constantly a target of
attack and we also have a performance
bottleneck so for instance maybe someone
can attack the central authority but
they can do a denial of service and make
the central authority go down so while
that's happening no new keys can be
issued in the system at all
so other authorities can be signing
things but these are useless until you
turn them into the attribute based
encryption keys
having just a single central authority
none of these minions because so what
you're saying is that you're decoupling
the signing their death and certifying
the attributes part
yeah so so what is what is slightly
different here is that sort of an
individual Authority does sort of
doesn't have to trust and a different
authority who's not the central
authority to sort of create his key so
he can sort of he doesn't have to trust
anyone else to sort of and even the
central authority so as long as you
trust a central authority you don't have
to trust all the other authorities in
the system and yet they can still
functionally give out keys so it's it's
certainly not an ideal solution this is
just I just wanted to show you sort of
what can be built without additional
crypto and so now we'll see what more
the additional crypto can do okay so the
previous work on this is Melissa's very
nice work from 2007 which does have a
central authority and has some
limitations on the policies and you need
a fixed set of authorities but what's
nice about this compared to the
engineering approach is that you don't
have to go to the central you don't have
to collect all your things would go to
the central authority sort of visit the
central authority at any time so central
authority doesn't need to know about
sort of everything all the attributes
you've had you can just sort of do this
in a more knuth us in any order and then
recently this was Susan proved by Jason
Chou with an approach suggested by
waters to remove the central authority
completely okay but in this system
there's there's still some restriction
on on the policies that you can get and
you need a fixed set of authorities yes
which the public sees this so the class
so the class of policies is doesn't
encompass sort of all boolean formulas
are all linear secret sharing things
which is what we're going for
okay okay so our system in comparison to
this we do have a trusted setup so we
need these global parameters to be to be
generating a nama licious way we don't
have a central authority so the person
who who does the trusted setup can just
publish these parameters and disappear
from the system they don't remain active
in the system expired expressive
policies I mean we can sort of handle
all boolean formulas over attributes or
more generally anything that can be
expressed as the linear secret sharing
scheme and and our authorities other
than just looking up these global
parameters don't need to coordinate with
each other at all yes kind of does hide
us oh I'm sorry I it's just a monotone
boolean formulas yes good good point
yeah so ands and ORS
no knots okay all right so the way that
our system works is that some trusted
entity publishes a set of global
parameters and then authorities can
arise at any time so to arise as an
authority you declare your attributes
and you publish a public key for each of
those attributes that you control so for
simplicity in this talk I'm always going
to just be associating each authority
with one attribute but more generally an
authority could have more attributes for
then they would need more public keys
okay so authorities horizon and publish
public keys a user has a global ID
associated to them and then can just go
and start collecting keys from different
authorities in any order at different
time and will be able to use these keys
together in decryption and so our our
main security challenge is still to
prevent users from colluding so if two
users have two different call IDs and
one has the attribute a and one has the
attribute B we still don't want to allow
these users to get together and decrypt
a ciphertext that's supposed to be
enforcing the policy a and B yes
so the global public parameters don't
need to know the total number of
attributes in the system so it's just
four for each authority if I control six
attributes I'll have six times the size
of my public parameters from someone who
controls one attribute but the global
parameters aren't affected by this okay
so we still don't want to allow
collusion on the second security
challenge which is new from single
Authority AV so we may have corrupt
authorities and we certainly want to
model that handles this otherwise we're
trusting all authorities and we might as
well make them one one thing and these
corrupt authorities can maliciously
choose their public parameters perhaps
and they can also conspire with collude
with users malicious users so we want a
security model that encompasses all of
these kinds of bad behavior so if as
usual formulate this as a game between a
challenge or an attacker and we're going
to think about the attacker as
controlling both some corrupt
authorities and some malicious users so
the game starts by publishing some
global parameters which are produced in
the trusted way by the Challenger and
then the attacker will imagine some
corrupt authorities that would like to
control so this is a static corruption
model for authorities and that has to
decide them at the beginning it's not
going to be adaptively corrupting them
through the game and so it sends a
challenger its set of corrupt
authorities at this point the Challenger
will create the good authorities and it
will create their public keys and send
these two to the attacker so now the
attacker gets to do adaptive key queries
so it'll decide on some identity
attribute pairs and it'll query the
Challenger for the corresponding keys
for these so it can it can use many
different identities to model many
different users and it's going to make
these queries adaptively so it does as
many of these as it was and then at some
point it has to decide on two messages
through the challenge ciphertext and
also declare a formula for the cipher
text to be encrypted to and this formula
can mix both attributes controlled by
corrupt authorities and attributes
controlled by code
and so for any entries controlled by
corrupt authorities it also sends the
Challenger the corresponding public keys
just to allow it to encrypt and the
restriction that we place on this
formula is that for any single global ID
the keys that the attacker has collected
in addition to any keys that could be
made from corrupt authorities should not
be sufficient to decrypt the ciphertext
but this is a per user restriction so if
the formula is something like a and B it
could have a key for a for one user and
a key for B for a different user and
this is still allowed as long as it
doesn't have enough keys for a single
user to decrypt and it's allowed yes so
this is just sort of in so I'm just
encapsulating that in the semantics of
an attribute so an attribute is is a
string as a binary string or something
and it's uniquely associated to an
authority yeah something like that yeah
so there's identifying information is
considered part of the definition of the
attribute okay other questions okay so
once the attacker has sent this to the
Challenger and it satisfies our
constraint that it shouldn't be
decrypted by keys for any single
individual the Challenger will flip a
random coin and use us to decide which
message to encrypt as usual it sends the
resulting ciphertext to the attacker the
attacker now gets to resume key queries
again with the same restriction that
these key queries shouldn't suddenly
allow it to decrypt for any one user it
does this for as long as it wants and
then finally it has to form a guess for
this hidden bit B so this is a usual
model and we say it's secure if of
course the guess for B is correct with
probability negligibly close to it so
this is static in terms of the corrupt
authorities they have to be decide the
beginning and it's adaptive in terms of
key queries okay any questions about the
security model
so the more general security model would
be if you could allow it to sort of
decide adaptively to corrupt in the
authority
so maybe the Challenger creates all the
authorities at some point in the game I
decide you know I'd like to corrupt that
authority and maybe that means for
instance so the Challenger has to send
me that Authority's secret key and so
maybe I could do this adapt early as it
going so we don't allow that because
you're saying that the authority chooses
the public key obviously yeah and then I
can say I'm corrupting this game getting
you secretly but public key isn't public
right right but so more generally you'd
allow both you'd say I could have
corrupt authorities that maliciously
generate and I can adopt Ally corrupt go
to authorities so the most general is
sort of allow corruption at any point
sort of at the beginning or as you go
and so though so we can handle at the
beginning so the corrupt authorities can
maliciously generate based on the pot
global parameters but we can't allow
that as you go corruption so that's an
open problem okay
all right so to talk about how we get
collusion and resistance let me just
first review how this is achieved in the
single authority setting so when we have
one Authority giving out all the keys
now what that Authority can do is he can
bind the keys of a certain user together
with some personalized randomness so
when a user comes to me if I'm the
authority I sort of pick some randomness
all associated with that user and I'll
refer to that and making every key I
make for them so every attribute key
given to this user will be associated
with this with this randomness and since
I'm sort of coordinating it they're all
worked together well but they won't work
with keys given to another user which
has some different randomness so you can
sort of think in the when users are
decrypting there in the decryption
process they're blinding factor that
they need to recover will be
personalized by this randomness so it'll
work fine for them because it's all the
same randomness for all their different
keys but it won't work in combining it
with other users but this is very
heavily using the fact that we have the
single authority and remember my
randomness each time I go and get a
different key and so this this approach
doesn't work when you have these
different authorities who don't talk to
each other so you can't get together and
decide on a random that's associated to
me as a user because they're not
supposed to need to know about each
other
so what we do in the multi authority
setting is we replace this by a public
hash function which we're gonna model as
a random Oracle so are all of our
results or should say a front R in the
random Oracle model okay and so at a
minimum this hash function of course
should be collision resistant which will
prevent users with different global IDs
from trivially breaking things so we
have this public hash function which
Maps global IDs into a group and now so
for authorities to sort of personalize
the users key when a user goes to get a
key from an authority Authority in the
process of creating that keith will look
up the hash of that users ID and we'll
use this in personalizing the key to
that user and so when the user goes for
different authority to create a key the
same thing will happen this Authority
will apply the public function to the
users ID and we'll use this to
personalise the key to that user and
this is how we will achieve collusion
resistance
yeah so I'm not gonna rely on hash of ID
being a hidden value I'm just going to
rely on that the hash of my ID is
different from the hash of your ID and
it will be embedded in your keys in such
a way that you know it but it's it's
stuck in there and so you'll see when we
do our decryption that if my value is
different from your value we won't be
able to to combine our keys are you
going to take an existing system and it
gives us some randomness it binds all
the attributes of the user together this
random random is you you can observe
that this randomness it's okay to be
public and therefore you can generate it
as values that it's someone close to
that I don't think this is exactly what
you get from taking an existing AV
system but it's sort of on the same
level of complication it's not very far
out from that okay so before I present
our exact construction let me just
review sort of the basic ingredients
that we'll use so we're gonna be using
bilinear groups I'm gonna first present
a prime order version of our
construction because it's easier there
are security guarantees are much weaker
in this case so I'll get to a composite
order version where you have better
proofs but the mechanics are the same so
let me start with the prime or diversion
so you have a bilinear group of prime
order P so E is going to denote our
bilinear map and our our hash function
models that are at model that's a random
Oracle is going to map into this
bilinear group okay and we're the main
other tool we're going to use is linear
secret sharing scheme so we're gonna use
this to take a secret which will be an
exponent mod P and split it into shares
according to our access policy so shares
in our system will each be associated
with attributes and so an authorized set
of shares will be one that can
reconstruct the secret as a linear
combination of these shares and these
will correspond to sets of attributes
that satisfy the formula and an
unauthorized set so if you're given
another authorized set of shares then
the seeker will still be information
theoretically hidden from you if you
just have those shares and this will
correspond to a set of attributes that's
not sufficient
before okay okay so it's now ready to
present our actual system so our global
setup will just decide on this group of
order P I'll generate it'll fix this
bilinear map it'll fix it generator G
and it will also decide on this public
hash function and these are our global
parameters okay
now to become an authority for a
particular attribute what you'll do is
you will choose two random exponents
alpha I and Y I so the index I here will
be associated with the attribute and the
public key will just be the pairing of G
with itself raised to the alpha I and G
to the Y I so to group elements for
attribute and the secret key will be
these two these two exponents okay so a
key for an identity and an attribute
will be a single group element which is
formed by taking G to the Alpha I for
that attribute multiplying this by hash
of the ID to the Y I so to encrypt when
an encrypted will do is they'll choose a
random exponent s mod P they'll split
this into shares according to the policy
they want to encrypt on there and
they'll also split 0 into shares
according to the same policy in the same
way and will sit and the 0 sharing is
going to help us achieve the collusion
resistance okay and so the cipher text
is formed by using the pairing of
Judah's itself to the S is a blinding
factor for the message so I'm assuming
here the message is in the target group
so I can multiply these things and then
I'm going to give out the pairings of G
with itself raised to these shares of s
additionally blinded by alpha X where
alpha X is the attribute corresponding
to the is for the attribute
corresponding to that chair and Rx is
some local randomness that I'm just
choosing freshly each time I'm
additionally going to give out G to the
Rx and G to the yxr X plus Omega X where
here the the Omega X and the lambda X
are are these shares so William two
extra shares of zero you know sorry the
lambda extra shoots of s the Omega s of
zero the alpha and the y are
corresponding to the attribute for that
chair and the R is random yes there's a
lot of things here but we'll see
in decryption how would roll each of
these things plays okay okay so to
decrypt in such a system obviously we
want to recover in so M is blinded by
this pairing race the s so as a sub-goal
we want to recover this okay so what do
we have well we have these shares of s
in the exponent if we have them by
themselves it would be easy because we
know how to reconstruct us as a linear
combination of these sheriffs so just do
that linear combination the exponent we
recover the blinding factor so what we
need to do is we need to strip off these
extra factors to get at these shares of
s okay so we need to compute these terms
alpha x RX we won't be able to do this
for every share we'll only be able to do
this for the shares for attributes we
have the keys for but that but if we're
allowed to decrypt that'll be enough
shares to reconstruct the secret so if
we have the key corresponding to this
alpha X then we compare our key with
this tree to the RX from the ciphertext
or we get what we want just with an
extra term okay so we're getting this
alpha X our X in the exponent that we
want but we're additionally getting a
term that now has the hash of our ID
embedded in it okay so now we've
introduced the hash of our ID into our
computation and now we have this to the
exponent Y X rx and again we need to get
rid of this so at this point we can
compute hash of our ID it's a public
function we compare this with compare
this with the G the YX rx plus Omega X
from the ciphertext and again we get
what we want just with an extra term and
now though this extra term has our hash
of ID in it and has an exponent which is
a share of zero okay so putting this
back together for the share so we have
the key we get this lambda X that we
want to get out the share of s but
additionally blinded by the share of 0
which is an exponent on our hash of ID
okay questions
so yeah
this is entourage you're not combining
it anything gets right
this is Parata you think that you're
gonna combine that right yes so these
are the pieces I'm going to combine so I
want to get them in this form first
before I combine anything so per
attribute that I have I'm gonna pull out
this eg G 2 lambda X which is to share
that I want and then I additionally have
this term with my hash of ID raised to a
share of 0 and now I want to pull my
shares and I want to reconstruct the
secret so I'm going to do the linear
combination in the exponent and this is
where the sharing of 0 becomes sort of
plays its role because when we do our
recombination in the exponent S will pop
out and 0 will pop out so that term will
go away so since these are shared in the
same way for the same policy a linear
combination that's supposed to be s for
the lambda X this will also give us 0
for the Omega X is no make it go away
ok so the share 0 will cancel out so
it's a very basic example let's look at
what happens for an Ann formula okay so
to do to share s on an and formula what
am I going to do it's going to take two
random pieces that some des and I'll
make lambda a my share for a lamb to be
my share for B so to share a 0 in the
same way I'm just gonna take two random
things that sum to 0 so I'll put Omega a
for a Omega B for B so someone who has
both of these keys will be able to get
at these two terms so through the
process we did on the last slide they'll
get something with an exponent of lambda
a and Omega a and something with an
exponent of of lambda B and Omega B and
this is assuming they have these two
keys for their same identity okay so
when they multiply these things together
so the reconstruction is in this case
linear combination is just a sum so you
just multiply things together and you
get something your exponent okay well
now sort of by the definition of the way
the sharing works the sum of the Omega
and Omega B was 0 so this term is just
say identity element in the group and
the sum of the lambda a lambda B is s so
this is the blinding factor that we
needed
so I mean so so buy good two different
authorities like all used didn't use the
same I think that's the point yes yes
they'll use the same ID so an idea is
something tied to you like a social
security number or something yes so so
the intermediate steps on the previous
slide for how to get a t-shirt okay so
um so the point of the intermediate
steps let me just go back a little bit I
don't know how to go back faster okay
so so they're sort of okay so you sort
of see why the sharing of zero is its
cancelling out okay so the point of the
intermediate steps is to make you
introduce your global your hash into
your computation because the ciphertext
is not personalized to a user right just
all it knows is attributes so the goal
of the intermediate steps is to make you
put your own hash of ID into the
computation so that we can rely on that
for collision resistance yes secret
sharing and poisoning it was knowledge
that only castle exactly that's exactly
the idea so we want to force but but we
can't put that in the ciphertext right H
of ID it doesn't belong in the
ciphertext we don't know who you are and
we're creating a subject so you have to
force you to put it in yourself and so
that's what we're doing with this
intermediate randomness we're sort of
just forcing you to use your key to get
rid of these intermediate terms and your
key is tied to the hash of your ID so
that's that's what we're going for at a
higher level so that makes sense yeah so
we have to make you put it in there
because it doesn't belong in the
ciphertext but yeah the idea is exactly
to do secret sharing where you're forced
to introduce your own identity so that
if you try to use inconsistent
identities yours these zeros shares
won't cancel out okay
so sorry no so this is actually for many
authorities because these different
attributes in the formula for the
secretary your keys can come from
different people so yeah they can come
from different people yeah so I so one
of your so in so in this example I could
be controlling attribute a and you could
be controlling attribute B and so this
would be the term they'd get from using
the key from you the other term they get
from using the key for me and then they
multiply them together just the ones
you're using in your policy yes so you
just need to encrypt you just need to go
collect the public keys for any of the
attributes you're referring to in your
formula right it's up to the encrypter
yeah so that so as an encrypted I decide
you know I think that Vinod controls a
and I trust his security so I will
encrypt to his public key for a yeah
okay makes sense
like if I wanted to be able keys but any
opportunity so in our system you would
need to have a public key for each one
so you'd have an exponentially large
public key but more internally you could
try to adopt what's called a large
universe ad system so we don't
explicitly do that but but one could try
to do that you see that's beautiful
it's great reach bit
they're diving things
so we are implicitly assuming sort of a
small universe a b e and you could try
to do it with large universe yeah as far
as I know I sort of have it sort of
haven't kept up with it but as far as I
know it's an open question I sort of
feel like the technology is probably out
there because there's a large universe a
B but but we don't explicitly do it so
it is an open question as far as I know
yeah there was a lot of noise nothing
figure it all out but what makes this
not work with any monitor makes you mean
what makes you need pairing um other
than I don't know how to do it I'm not
sure I have another I'm not sure I have
a good answer off the top of my head I'm
yeah I'm and and and certainly for the
security proof I mean we can it so for
the prime order version we only have a
generic group model proof so for to do
the static security proof we even need
more than this we need composite order
pairings and and then we're using
pairing in ways that are very very
necessary in my mind but um yeah they
don't have a quick answer to that
Neverest might request yeah I'm not sure
I
yeah I guess I'm sort of just also just
having the freedom not to sort of commit
yourself to an attribute space ahead of
time yes well actually this this
construction the security is only proven
in the generic group model so the point
of our composite rotor thing is to get
static assumptions ideally you would
want a prime order version from things
like dealain but the static thing does
have I'm sorry
composite order thing does have static
assumptions this is only a generic route
proof at this point yes so we'll get to
that if I have time okay okay and so
this is the mechanics of how the
system's works right so the idea for for
collision resistance as we as we've seen
is if you have different hashes of IDs
you have different bases on these
exponents which are shares of zero so
they won't just solve in the exponent
anymore and they won't cancel oh okay so
that's intuition so unfortunately I'm
not going to talk about the generic
group because it's not at all insightful
but so to get a static security proof
we're going to use dual system
encryption and composite ordered groups
so I mean just try to give you a brief
overview of what dual system encryption
is okay so this was introduced by
Watters in 2009 and the main idea is
we're gonna have two types of keys and
two types of ciphertext so if normal
keys and normal ciphertext which are
which are used in the real system and
they decrypt as normal so a key will
decrypt the ciphertext if it's supposed
to and so on okay but we for the proof
we additionally have these objects
called semi functional keys and
semi-functional ciphertext and these
have the the functionality that a normal
key will still decrypt a semi functional
ciphertext and in normal ciphertext
still be decrypted by some my functional
key but suddenly if I take us on my
functional key and try to capture crypto
semi-functional server text things go
horribly wrong so the Shin will
always fail in this case okay so these
are sort of two objects that just don't
play nicely together all right and the
idea for the proof
and we're roughly gonna show that these
types of keys and these types of cipher
texts are indistinguishable to a certain
point okay so the proof so this has been
used to do a bunch of stuff that I'm not
going to talk about so the idea for the
hybrid security proof is we're gonna
start with a real game so in the real
game we have the real system normal Keys
and the normal ciphertext and so we're
going to go through some transitions of
games where first we just changed the
ciphertext semi-functional so at this
point keys are still decrypting the
semi-functional ciphertext everything
still looks sort of the same I'm gonna
argue the attacker can't change their
advantage because they can't really
distinguish between these cases okay
then one by one so we'll keep our cipher
text on my functional and one by one
we're gonna change our keys to be
somewhat functional gonna keep arguing
the attacker can't not change its
advantage in a non-negligible way and
we're gonna end up at a game where
everything's semi-functional now it's a
lot easier for the simulator to run this
game because it doesn't have to produce
things they're actually capable of
decrypting each other and now Security's
a lot easier to prove just directly so
that so that's the motivation that's
where we're trying to get to now you
should be a little skeptical about this
this framework I've just presented so
there's a catch so at the point where so
ass architects become semi-functional
keys or normal find everything would
still decrypt in theory not that much
has changed okay so now we're thinking
about this step where ciphertext has
become semi functional and our first key
is going to change from normal a semi
functional so we want to create a
simulator that's gonna create this key
in such a way that if it's a my
functional then the answer that whether
or not a semi functional depends on the
answer to this hard problem the
simulator is trying to solve so the
simulator should not know the nature of
the key itself so just be producing this
key that's either normal or semi
functional but it won't know itself so
it also with the adversaries advantage
changes it can use this to answer the
hard problem okay so the challenges
though we're we're doing an adaptive key
model right so similar it has to be able
to make this key for anything and it
also needs to make the semi functional
ciphertext for anything so the attacker
can't ask for a key that's able to
decrypt but the simulator can try to do
that so maybe it makes this unknown key
such that it should decrypt the
ciphertext and then it seems that it can
test for itself by just trying to
decrypt so if it tries to D if it tries
to decrypt and it was normal it'll work
and if it tries to decrypt and it was
semi functional then it'll fail and now
it seems a simulator is answered its own
question okay so this is a paradox we
need to avoid it okay so the way that we
avoid this is by introducing something
we call nominal semi functionality okay
what this means is that things will be
sort of semi functional and named but it
would but it won't hurt decryption so
it'll happen is the simulator will make
a key that's either normal or nominal
semi functional and then if it makes a
cypher text it can decrypt even if it
was nominal semi functional so it has
these sort of semi functional components
they'll magically cancel out with the
cipher text and decryption will fit will
succeed anyway okay so what we're gonna
have the simulator do is it will make a
key and a cipher texts that are
correlated so if in the simulators view
decryption will always work because of
this correlation but we're gonna hide
this correlation from the attacker so in
the attackers view it should look like
these things are just distributed as
regular semi functional things and so
what why is this possible so it
separates the attackers view from the
simulators view is the attacker is not
allowed to ask for a key that's actually
capable of decrypting the cipher text so
as long as you look at a key in a server
texts that are not capable of decrypting
then it will look random and semi
functional terms but if they actually if
the key actually could decrypt the
cipher text this correlation would be
revealed yes
what and is it hard to come up with a
semi-functional ciphertext on your own
just from the public around
um it depends on the system and what
yeah I think it should be yeah it should
be hard yeah because if you could then
you could test it against the ciphertext
and you could see so yeah it's gonna be
hard to come up with one on your own so
that public parameters were sort of only
allow the public parameters are really
only sort of specify things in the
normal space
and the semi functional space will just
be coming from the simulator of the game
okay other questions yeah yeah so what
the simulator is doing is he's actually
changing it from normal to nominal
semi-functional
in reality and then you're shorter so
you can sort of thinking about is the
computational step will be changing it
from normal des nominal and then there's
just an information theoretic step we
argue it's actually identically
distributed in the attackers view to
regular semi-functional so it's really
sort of two-step process just one of
them's information-theoretic so we sort
of swallow it and still argument yeah
yes I go inside so to prove nominal so
sort of like the definition of nominal
is tied to sort of the decryption
functionality of the system right so if
I'm gonna do this for a B and then do
this for HIV I have to go in and tailor
it to the functionality of the system
because there's a correlation that
should only appear when I can actually
decrypt so it should have Ali dependent
sort of what the definition of
decryption functionality is so I have to
tailor it to every system but this
framework we've used quite generally so
those are the same framework that we use
for IV HIV lots of other things yes yeah
yeah so um so we've written it as an
abstraction a few times and other times
we haven't we haven't been consistent
about that but yeah there are a few
papers in which we have sort of
specified this as properties and one
since we did it for for leakage
resilience as well and a few times we've
done that without leakage resilience
they think yes
no I really don't think so this is not
necessarily evidenced in every time it's
used but the original paper for instance
that that brentd proves security for I
BES fully secured IB and HIV from dealin
and and decisional bilinear
diffie-hellman and a lot of the dual
system systems have started out in
composite order groups and I'm now
migrated in the prime order groups proof
MD line so typically in the composite
order systems we've we found a
convenient to use a small number of
assumptions like three or four that are
all sort of variants of the same kind of
assumption and then typically when these
things get transferred to prime order
groups they all collapsed a deal in but
that's sort of an ongoing process of
ongoing work
oh yeah yeah so this is sort of a medic
conjectures that we have that sort of
everything that we're doing in these
composite order groups from these
particular kind of static assumptions
really should be dealing in prime motor
groups with some more work and so this
has been done for some particular
systems so for instance it's been done
for single Authority a B by Okimoto and
takashima and it was and it was done in
the original dual system paper for IB
and HIV okay so so why are composite
order groups so good for your dual
system encryption so let me give you a
sense of why they're very convenient but
I did but I I do not believe this is
inherent it's just a nice tool for
making things sort of prettier so you
can understand what's going on okay so
where you consider a compositor group
whose order is going to be an order
product of three distinct primes okay so
you have a bilinear map and what these
three distinct primes gives us is it
gives us subgroups of each prime order
two orthogonal to each other under the
bi-linear map so if I take an element to
the blue subgroup when I pair it with
something from the red subgroup I always
get the identity so what this gives me
is it gives me sort of three orthogonal
spaces to work in this is a very nice
setting for dual system encryption
because I can do my main scheme in one
space my semi functionality will live in
another space and then it's very easy
for me to have normal and semi
functional things work together because
I just had this extra space that's
orthogonal so it's not hurting anything
but suddenly when I have two semi
functional things they'll interact in
this semi functional space and that will
stop decryption so it's just a very
convenient framework for dual system yes
yeah abelian groups so these are cyclic
groups actually yeah yeah it's it's
still cyclic okay and so this is where
for complexity assumptions we are going
to assume that this factorization is
secret so it should be hard to find a
non-trivial factor event so this is
where for instance and the public
parameters were maliciously generator
someone knew the factorization they
would be able to break things so what so
we do need that to stay secret okay okay
so what kind of problems do do we rely
on in these groups so in general we rely
on things to belong to the class of
subgroup decision assumptions and these
are roughly saying that in the generic
group model if you're given a random
elements from different subgroups so the
only way you can tell them apart is just
by pairing them against each other and
seeing if you get the identity or not
they're sort of testing for these
orthogonal ities okay so as an example
well okay so more generally if we have a
group order which is a product of many
primes so for each subset of the indices
of these Prime's we have a corresponding
subgroup whose order is the product of
those Prime's and suppose you're given
say a random element of the subgroup of
order P 1 a random element of group of
order P 2 times P 3 and you're trying to
distinguish something that's either from
P 2 before or from P 3 P 4 so we're in
the generic group model what are you
gonna do you're just gonna pair these
things together so if you pair your your
challenge element T against G well P 1
doesn't appear in either of the cases of
T so it'll just get the identity element
both times okay if you try to pair it
against H in one case you'll get a
contribution from the P two terms the
other case you'll get a contribution
from the P three terms so each each time
they'll just get some random looking
group element and you won't know which
subgroup it's coming from so you wanna
be able to distinguish these cases so
more generally general subgroup decision
assumption says that if you're given a
bunch of things which are random
elements from different subgroups so I'm
illustrating subgroups here as being
subsets of the different primes and
you're trying to this thing
Challenge which is either from one case
or the other case as long as sort of all
the things you're given how our
correspond to sets that intersect both
cases or neither case and so whenever
you try a testings preparing you either
get something both times or you get
nothing both times and so at least in
the generic group model should be a hard
problem okay so these are the kind of
assumptions that we rely on we use a few
more than one I think it's three or four
specific instances of this and I think
we for this for this work we have one
that's the static assumption that it
doesn't quite fall into this framework
but general and dual system encryption
you can usually work in this class of
assumptions right so we don't make the
general assumption explicitly you could
yeah except and for this particular for
this system we actually have one that
doesn't fall in the general it's a
static one that doesn't quite fall but
but yeah okay so so the way that our
system in composite order groups works
is in in sub group one is really our
main space where the scheme is happening
really just does it happened before so
everything is some group one is the same
and then our semi function so if
functional things will just spread into
these other spaces so so my functional
ciphertex have additional components in
both spaces and we're going to have two
types of semi-functional keys so maybe I
should ask at this point how when should
I stop how much time do I five minutes
okay okay so I'll try to tell you the
main idea of how this nominal part works
okay so so why why do we have two types
of semi-functional keys so to do that to
to do this step where I'm making things
nominal and then I'm arguing that the
attacker can't tell information
theoretically what I'm going to do is
I'm going to rely on the fact that okay
so so remember we have this sharing of
zero in the in the ciphertext right so
it's going to happen in the semi
functional ciphertext is we're
additionally going to be sharing this
sharing of 0 is going to spread into
these other subspaces except it'll be
sharing something random
so then you know semi-functional
ciphertext is sharing something random
in the red space and random in the green
space so now if you try to decrypt with
say a semi functional kia has components
in the red space you'll be constructing
a random secret in the red space which
will prevent you from decrypting okay so
the way we're going to achieve nominal
semi functionality so the simulator
can't test things for itself as we're
gonna say that we're sharing something
random but we're actually going to be
sharing zero again so a nominal
semi-functional ciphertext for instance
it's gonna be sharing something random
in the green say but actually sharing
zero in the red and then our key that
we're gonna not know the form of is
going to be coming into the red space
but since we were really sharing zero
there if we try to decrypt we won't see
the contribution of the red pieces okay
so we need to hide what we're sharing
and a linear secret sharing scheme so if
you have only one key in one ciphertext
this is not too hard because you don't
have enough attributes to decrypt so
essentially this the shares that you
don't have the keys for those attributes
are blinded so information theoretically
in this and and the public parameters
are just in GP once they don't give out
any information about what's going on in
the rest face so when you really have
you some flying to things then you have
some shares that are that our
information theoretically revealed but
they aren't enough to reconstruct the
secret so if you really only have shares
that are insufficient to reconstruct the
secret the value that you're sharing
zero is information theoretically hidden
but now I have a collusion problem in
the information theoretic world because
if you had different keys that were all
different revealing information
theoretically different shares you would
see that you were sharing zero so what I
do in the hybrid organization to get
around this so let me let me skip ahead
a little bit it's mostly just what I
said ok so the hybrid works by first my
ciphertext will go semi-functional and
then my first key will be so my
functional type once this is living in
the red space and then I'll change it to
be typed - and then my next key will be
some more functional of one type one
I'll change it to B type - so important
thing about this is I only have so when
a key first becomes semi-functional it
does so in the red space where it's sort
of
the only key that's happening there so
so I'm bringing things in to be somebody
functional we're really only I'm dealing
with one key and one ciphertext at a
time and this allows me to make my
information theoretic argument go
through and then I change it to the
other space so that I've sort of saved
my work and making it semi functional
and then I can move on so because I only
have one key coming in in this red space
at a time that's where my information
theoretical argument lives then I change
it to being semi-functional of the other
form and so the sort of as I'm changing
this third key the keys behind it aren't
leaking information about what's going
on in the red space because now they've
been changed into the green space yes
reasons
but every time I switch from type 1 to
type 2
yeah so so so the way the stops go is
computationally I'm going to be sharing
zero in the ciphertext in the red space
and bringing in my key in the red space
and then information theoretically I
argue I was really sharing random and
then I computationally change my key so
now it's random random in the red space
now I do a computational change so just
sort of flip it to the green subgroup
and then and then I do an information
and then I'm really sharing zero again
in the ciphertext of bringing the next
key information theoretically I'm
sharing random and I and I a to write
this okay there are questions so so this
is really the main idea of how that
proof works and then when I get to the
end and everything semi-functional it's
not too hard so so the real sort of
challenge here is just keeping the fact
that you're giving out many keys from
destroying your information theoretic
security and so the way to do that is
usual organize your Hybrid around it to
bring things into one space move them to
the other space so they don't ruin
things for the next key and then keep
moving for it so this can be
accomplished just with a hybrid there is
one more slight slight issue with this
which the information theoretic argument
is also sensitive to how often you use
an attribute okay because these shares
are blinded by terms that are fixed with
the attribute so if you use an attribute
several times in your formula this
information security would go away so we
need to specify that you can only use an
attribute once in each formula now you
can design the system around this by
just taking it it's if you really want
to use an attribute six times for
instance you just encode that attribute
it's six different things that really
you know mean the same thing but
semantically are different and you can
do this but it's a bit of an efficiency
issue so be nicer to get rid of it but
we don't know how at this point
okay so so that's the system that's the
hybrid proof
okay this I've sort of already said okay
and so I'll skip over the summary and
just go to the open questions because
the thing is more interesting
so obviously prime water groups under
simple assumptions is where you'd want
this to go there's ongoing work in this
area for specific systems and so
transformations in general so this is
very promising
adaptive corruption I think would be
also a very interesting thing to try to
get so adaptive corruption of
authorities as the system is online yeah
we don't know how to do that but it
would be would be a nice contribution
also distributed set up you could try to
replace this trusted global set up by a
multi-party computation for instance
trying to make it efficient so that's an
interesting direction
removing the random Oracle it's sort of
one that I find the most interesting and
I have absolutely no idea how to do so
if people have thoughts on this please
let me know I think that would be great
and I always say we sort of always have
the question of can we do even more
expressive functionality we go beyond
linear secret sharing um yeah I don't
really have any ideas on that right now
either but um so I think these are sort
of interesting questions to do to do
next yeah and a large universe I didn't
put out there but it should be up there
I thought that that should be done yeah
and I'm not aware of it being done yet
the same guys yeah now that's another
one that should be up there I sort of
didn't know if I had time to technically
talk about it but yeah getting rid of
this restriction would be a big deal and
it's it's in single authority a be2 this
is just inherited from single authority
so it's a problem there as well that we
still don't know how to get around you
can get around it so if you're willing
to go to a static security in terms of
queries then you don't need any such
thing but so if we're fully secured ABI
I believe it's a restriction there and
sort of every system we have now so that
would be very nice to get rid of a
priori found and the size of the formula
agenda
well you place an a priori bound on the
number of times an attribute can be used
what's up for small universe it's
equivalent to bounding the whole thing
for a large universe it may not be but
yes yeah you're three primes
security versus factorization attacks
obviously yeah um that's a very relevant
question I I don't know I sort of don't
keep on I mean really we're thinking
this is a tool for eventually getting a
system in Prime's so it's not so I sort
of wouldn't want to live with that long
term really not sort of advocating that
as you know where you'd want to be so
the goal would be just this is sort of a
nice conceptual idea that should be
ported into primordial groups towards
maybe more cumbersome and so we we just
think it's a nicer process to do it as a
two-part stuff but if I'm really going
to deploy the system I would do step two
and I would make it prime order first
um so there is not as clear to me so
yeah so I mean if you created some bag
if you sort of knew something about the
hash function you know that would be a
problem but it's like the hash function
was something publicly agreed to be good
then I it's less clamping maybe so yeah
the global setup is sort of sort of less
worrisome in the prime order version
that we have now but I should mention
sort of for the way that these things
are typically transferred from composite
order to prime order so what's more
worrisome about the primal reversion is
not the global set up but just the fact
that it's only a generic group proof but
if I were going to do this if we're
gonna take the system and put it in
prime order the way I would typically
start is I would sort of say okay I want
these orthogonal subspaces so I'm going
to build them into B subspaces and
exponent vectors in prime order groups
and then someone and then the global set
up would have to establish basis for
these sub groups in the exponent and if
someone knew the basis for the semi
functional spaces that would be a bad
thing
so probably in that transformation
process I would introduce things that I
wanted to keep secret into the global
setup so the way it is now the goal was
set up looks pretty good it's just a
group then as a hash function but
probably to give the static security I
to introduce things that I wanted to
keep secret but maybe not I'm not a door
would depend on how how you did the
transformation